avenue non directement 19 20 il n'y a
pas de gaz où il ya doute ça se tape je
voulais vous présenter en tout cas la
doublure de janis tout à l'heure dans
l'édifice voici notre personnage
principal de spielberg file alors
qu'est-ce que five i'll c'est un dessin
animé qui bat tous les records d'entrées
aux états unis pour vous envie sagnier
pour toute l'équipe du 19 20
on a fait venir féval avoriaz c'est
quand même pas rien spielberg lui a fait
venir file d'europe centrale
car c'est l'histoire des migrants à qui
on a raconté les souris bien sûr qu'ils
avaient plus de fromage aux etats-unis
et pas un chat donc le royaume voilà en
conséquence maintenant je vais me
tourner vers johnny johnny qui est là à
double titre d'abord vous savez qui est
au jury mais vous savez aussi qu'il est
la beauté de terminus
ça ne me serait pas une manne mort qu'on
petit voilà j'allais dire johnny qu'il
faut insister là dessus que le public ne
confondent pas c'est pas un arrangement
alors il ya eu je tenais aussi à dire
que le film était en compétition on m'a
posé la question depuis que je suis là
on m'a dit alors est le film est en
compétition est ce que c'est parce que
vous considérez que le film n'est pas
assez bien je tiens à dire que ce n'est
pas ça du tout c'est que le film a été
terminé d'être monté il y a à peine dix
jours ont fait pas s'engager et ce qui
apparaît ce qui fait que bon la disant
la classification les les films nominés
enfin dominer le ce qu'ils avaient
préparé de tout voilà il fallait qu'il
soit vu deux mois al avance donc il ne
pouvait pas de toute façon être en
compétition
et puis au contraire c'est très bien
parce que c'est libre et s'éprend
et de toute façon est de toute façon
s'il avait été en compétition je ne
serais pas là en tant que jury et puis
et de toute façon nous aurions gagné
j'avais une autre race rare mais montre
et se dilue une sacrée culture là vous
avez eue avec la mouche première version
vous êtes vous n'avez pas vu la première
heure
bien sûr mais vous avez parlé vraiment
et l'homme qui votre si vous l'aviez pas
vu si bien sûr mais vous aviez en
mémoire les séquences et moi je les aie
furent mais oui parce que ce sont des
films qui ont marqué ma jeunesse et pour
moi le vrai film fantastique c'est pas
obligatoirement des films d'horreur
c'est pas obligatoirement de
l'hémoglobine partout pour moi c'est des
films dans laquelle on peut rêver on
peut rêver dans l'âge dans l'homme qui
rétrécit par exemple pour moi qui tu es
un des meilleurs films de science
fiction parce que c'est ça que j'appelle
la scientifique la science fiction
ces défis dans laquelle on peut rêver ce
tome qui qui qui qui retrace situation
sais pas pourquoi et puis il ya des
scènes extraordinaires par exemple sa
femme il devient la même taille que
c'est que ce petit la maison par rapport
à sa femme
et puis alors il ya le chat qui essayent
de l'attraper alors il devient de plus
en plus petits puis alors il finit par
habitant dans la maison de poupée de sa
fille
et puis devient de plus en plus petite
pièce il ya cette fan film où il y à
l'araignée qui essayent de qui essayent
de l'attraper et puis lui prend il
épingle qui n'est pas normal quand on
coud et pour lui ça devient ça devient
une défense alors y aura t il alors à
tous j'aimerais bien vous poser une
autre question
elle a été posée sans foi en fait là on
voit une carrière nouvelle côté cinéma
goda costa gavras et pierre william
vaines
c'est un choix délibéré parallèlement
une très très belle carrière qui
continue mais qui change elle aussi qui
est intéressant qui est beaucoup plus
personnel côté musique et pour mener les
deux de front
c'est décidé j'essaye oui enfin c'était
pas facile mais bon j'essaie mais
j'essaye dans le sens de ne de toute
façon ne jamais mélanger ni la musique
ni le cinéma
bon ça je lui ai déjà dit rien de
nouveau là-dedans bon quand je fais
quand je fais une année cinéma où j'ai
dit j'ai dit j'ai des offres
intéressantes je me consacre au cinéma
et puis une autre
voilà
il se trouve que c'est vrai que
peut-être on peut en avoir ras-le-bol de
voir en ce moment parce qu'on voit
beaucoup je viens de sortir un disque
donc j'ai fait quatre motions pour
l'album d'envoi pour à la sortie d'un
film ce qui fait peut être beaucoup dans
ce cas que je sais c'est que je m'en
vais ok mais on regrette pas de vous
avoir vu ce soir johnny merci en tous
les cas là c'est la fin c'est le terme
de cette émission d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions vive le festival
d'avoriaz et